[موسيقى]
مساء الخير يا
جماعه مخير
تاني ده جسم
الانسان لو احنا قسمنا جسم الانسان نصين
معظمنا هيتخن فيين شبه بعض بالظبط بس في
الواقع ده مش صحيح جسم الانسان من بره
يعني ممكن يكون متشابه بس احنا لو دقنا في
التفاصيل لا يمكن تقول ان النصين شبه بعض
بالظبط كمان لو بصينا لجسم الانسان من جوه
هنلاقيه قمه في الاختلاف بدايه من راسك
والمخ نص مخك اليمين بيعمل حاجه نص مخك
الشمال مش بيعملها كمان لو نزلنا لصدرك
وبطنك رينك مش زي بعض نص قلبك اليمين
مختلف عن نص قلبك الشمال شمالك في المعده
والطحال ويمينك فيه الكب حتى اطرافك نصك
اليمين بيعمل حاجه الشمال مش بيعملها
والعكس ده
ايه ده لون ابيض طيب هو ايه اللون الابيض
اصلا ممكن تفتكروا ان ده اكت سؤال متخلف
ممكن حد يساله بس في الواقع لو احنا فكرنا
شويه هنلاقي الابيض ما هو الا مزيج من سبع
الوان م لهمش اي علاقه ببعض اتمزج كلهم
فدونا لوحه لونها ابيض حتى الالوان اللي
بتعمل اللون الابيض دي لو فكرنا شويه
هنلاقي ان كل لون مش لون واحد فمثلا
الاورنج ما هو الا الاحمر والاصفر والاخضر
ما هو الا الازرق والاصفر
وهكذا هي دي اللا
سيمتريه اكتشفت مؤخرا عن نفسي اني مليان
بتناقضات رهيبه اولا انا مش شخص اقدر اقول
عن نفسي ان انا سعيد ومعظم الناس يعني
شايفن ان انا متشائل في الواقع انا ما
بحبش اقول عن نفسي ان انا متشائم بفضل
اقول عن نفسي ان انا واقعي اكتر بس اذا
كان الواقع شق فاشه انا
متشائم انا من اكت الناس اللي بتكره فكره
الخروج من الاساس بس اكتر حاجه ببقى عايز
اعملها واكتر كلمه بقولها يلا
نخرج يمكن فكره الخروج مربوطه شويه بفكره
اني هبقى مرغم اجتماعيا اني ابتسم في وش
ناس
معرفهاش بس انا من اكتر الناس اللي بحب
اتعرف على ناس جديده واعمل صداقات مختلفه
بس في يوم من الايام وانا بحاول اتفادى اي
لقاء جسدي مع امثالي من بني البشر قررت
اني هتفرج على كل حلقات مسلسل برري زنات
اوه اوكي حلقه في الثانيه في الثالثه
لغايه ما وصلت القصه حل معايا قوي القصه
دي كان فيها طفل عنده فشل في الكبد وكان
معاه ورقه او بروشور مستني الدكتور يمضيها
عشان تتحق امنيته قبل ما يموت بصراحه انا
استغربت الموضوع ده قوي وقررت ان انا لازم
ادور على اصل وفصل الورقه دي وقد كان
اكتشفت انها تبع ميكا ويش فاونديشن في
امريكا بحثت عنهم هما مين وبيعملوا ايه
لغايه ما وصلت لقصه ده باد كيد ده باد كيد
هو كان طفل عنده سرط
وكانت امنيته انه يقابل باتمان الدنيا في
الاول كانت هتعدي عادي هيجيب واحد لابس
باتمان يجيله البيت يلعبوا مع بعض شويه
ويروحوا بس في الواقع مش ده اللي حصل اللي
حصل ان ميكش فاونديشن جمعت 7000 فولنتير
وحولوا سان فرانسيسكو لثم سيتي رئيس
الشرطه طلع على التلفزيون بيطلب مساعده ده
باد كيد ذا باد كيد نزل مع باتمان ركبوا
البات موبيل مشوا في شوارع سان فرانسس سو
حربه ده جوكر حربه ده بينجوين وانقذوا
الست كانت مربوطه على شريط
الترامب بعد ما خلصوا ده ب كدهد راح عشان
يستلم مفتاح المدينه مش كده وبس كمان
اوباما طلع يشكره كل ده حصل عشان يحققه
للطفل ده
امنيته اول ما خلصت قرايه القصه حسيت
بانبهار غريب وقررت ان الناس دي انا لازم
اكلمها فها يا جماعه انا ممكن اساعدكم لو
انتوا هتيجوا مصر مافيش طيب انا ممكن
اساعدكم فتحها في مصر طب ردوا عليا طيب بس
للاسف كانت لحيا لمتون دي فكره ان هم
مايردوش عليا دي نرفزتني وعصبت ني ويعني
خلاص بس في نفس الوقت حسيت بكلمه البصيص
اللي بيقولوا عليه ده وفي الواقع ده كان
احساس مش مفهوم بالمره المهم سبتني منهم
خالص وقررت اني هدور في مصر على اي جمعيه
مماثله عشان اشتغل معاها بس برض للاسف
مالقيتش اللي كنت بدور عليه فكره اني
مالقيش اللي بدور عليه دي كانت معصباني
بطريقه زياده عن اللزوم وفعلا معرفش ليه
يمكن لان وضع الاطفال في مصر كل يوم من سي
لاسوا هم اقليات الاقليات في الحقوق واكتر
فئه معرضه لانتهاكات يوميه لحقوق اطفال ما
بتعلمش اطفال بتضرب اطفال شوارع اطفال مش
لاقي اكل وعلاج اطفال
بتموت انا عايزكم تتخيلوا معايا حاجه انت
في اوضه
ظلمه
الاوضه دي حتنها رمادي من كتر التراب عادي
طيب انت على سرير بيعمل اسخف صوت ممكن حد
يسمعه حتى لو تحركت سني
واحد عادي طيب انت متوصل باجهزه وحقن
وادويه شل حركتك وماثر عليك نفسيا وجسديا
اكيد مش
عادي سيبك من كل ده وتخيل ان اللي موجود
في الاوضه دي على السرير ده توصل بالاجهزه
دي هو طفل صغير مريض الموضوع مش ادامي
بالمره بس الغريب في الطفل ده انه لسه
بيحلم لسه عنده امل ان مستقبله لسه موجود
ومن هنا جت فكره دويش فاكتوري دويش
فاكتوري هي مبادره طلابيه هدفها الاساسي
مساعده الاطفال في مصر بتنقسم المبادره
لقسمين القسم الاول هو تحقيق امنيات
الاطفال من سن ا 14 سنه اللي عندهم ظروف
صحيه بتهدد حياتهم دي كانت هتكون الفكره
في الاول يعني كمحك لفكره ميك وش فاونديشن
بس ساعتها حسيت ان انا ما سعش الاطفال ما
عملتش حاجه ما غيرتش الواقع والواقع لازم
يتغير فجت الفكره الثانيه او الجزء الثاني
وهو القيام بفعاليات للدفاع عن حقوق
الاطفال في مصر بدايه من حقهم في الصحه
والتربيه والتعليم لمنع العنف ومنع الختان
ومنع ماله
الاطفال كنت فاكر ان امنيات الاطفال في
مصر مش هتختلف كتير عن اي مكان في العالم
لانهم تقريبا متعرضين لنفس الظروف
والافكار عن طريق النت والتلفزيون بس
اتصدمت صدمه كبيره لما رحت كلمت استاذ
دكتور اطفال عندنا في المستشفى يعني عشان
يساعدنا حكيت له كل حاجه وسابني لغايه ما
خلصت خالص وقال لي بص هو انا مش عايز
اصدمك بس انت لو دخلت يا عنبر من العنابر
دي اللي يمكن هتلاقي اللي انت بتتكلم فيه
انت هتلاقي اطفال عايزه مخده وملايه واكله
من اللي بيسمعوا عنها في
التليفزيون بصراحه انا ما كنتش مصدقه في
الاول بس قررت ان انا اهق نفسي للاسود
فرحت كلمت استاذ دكتور طب نفسي اطفال عشان
تساعدنا في فهم عقليه الطفل وافضل طريقه
نتعامل بيه معاه وساعتها قررنا ان احنا
هنعمل ايموشنال كوتشين للمريض والاهل من
اكتر الحاجات المفيده اللي الدكتور قالتها
لنا هي اننا لازم نساعد الطفل في فهم ان
الصحه مش معناها غياب المرض وان كونه مريض
مش معناه انه ما يقدرش يعمل حاجه بل
بالعكس هو يقدر يعمل كل حاجه هو نسه فيها
بس بعد ما يقوي نفسه ويتعود على حالته
الجديده بعد المرض من اك الحاجات المفيده
برض الدكتور قالتها لنا هي اننا نفهم
الطفل ونفهم مرضه بس ماتطفش مع مرضه اكتر
من فهمنا ليه بس في الواقع ده كان سماعه
اسهل بكتير من
تنفيذه ده
ابراهيم ابراهيم هو طفل
يتيم عنده 11 سنه في 5
ابتدائي ابراهيم عنده مرض سرطان
الدم اول مره قابلنا ابراهيم كانت عملناها
عنده في الدار وساعتها ما كناش نعرف انه
مريض بعدها فتره لقينا الدار منزل سورته
وكاتب انه محجوز في المستشفى ساعتها حسيت
ان يمكن ده اكتر طفل انا اعرفه يستحق ان
احنا نحقق له امنيته وفي اسرع
وقت اول مره رحنا لابراهيم كان زعلان
ومتضايق ا كانت نظرته لينا بتقول
اه ناس جايه تزورني ومش هشوفها تاني خشوا
خشوا اي حاجه كنا بنقولها لابراهيم في
اليوم ده كانت اجابتها عنده انا عايز اخرج
من المستشفى واحنا قاعدين داخل علينا
اتننين خلصوا علاجهم وجايين بيسلموا عليه
وبيقعدوا ان هم زوروه تاني بس الغريب في
نظرته ان كانت بتقول انا مش عايز اشوفكم
تاني انا بس عايز اخرج من
هنا كنا بنلعب لعبه فيها سبايدر مان عشان
بيحبه وفي وسط اللعب قال بص لو انا كسبت
يبقى اخرج من المستشفى انما لو انت كسبت
وسكت كنت متخيل ان دي ممكن تكون اسوا حاله
ممكن يكون فيها طفل على الاطلاق بس برض
كنت
غلطان المره الانيه لما رحنا لابراهيم كان
حالق شعره بسبب الكيماوي
اول ما دخلنا عليه قال بص بقيت شبه
الجمعه الكيماوي والادويه كان مثره عليه
فوق ما هو يتحمى ل كان قادر لا ياكل ولا
يشرب ولا حتى
يتكلم لما سالناه مش نفسك تاكل حاجه بص
للمشرف بتاعه وهو مكسوف وقال لنا اه نفسي
اكل من ماكدونالدز الساندوتش المدور
والبطاطس
والبيبسي احنا في اليوم ده للاسف ما قدرنا
نقعد مع ابراهيم زي كل مره عشان تعبه
وارهاقه نزلنا اليوم ده واحنا عندنا
اكتئاب وحزن غريب ومش عارفين نعمل له ايه
احنا تاثرنا بمرض وحالته النفسيه واحنا مش
في الموضوع اصلا فما بالكم بيه
هو ساعتها كنا لازم نقف مع نفسنا شويه
ونفكر ونفكر بصوت اعلى احنا بصين على
ابراهيم على انه كتله واحده جوانبها كلها
زي بعض ما فيهاش اختلاف فقررت ان احنا
لازم ندور على الاختلافات في قصه ابراهيم
ندور على اجزاء الزل الغريبه اللي مش
موجوده في البازل الكبير اللي اسمه
ابراهيم مريض اللوكيميا جمعنا اجزاء
البازل دي وديتنا صوره اكبر والصوره
التانيه دي هي اللي فعلا نشتغل
عليها المره اللي بعديه لما رحنا لابراهيم
جبنا له لعب كتير كلها على شكل سبايدر مان
وفرح بيه قوي المره اللي بعديها جبنا له
كتب رسم وتلوين وقعدنا نرسم ونلون ونهزر
واكتر حاجه اثرت فيها لما شفناها
بيضحك اول ما طلع من المستشفى ورحنا له
الدار جبنا له لبس سبايدر مان فرح بيه فرح
مش طبيعي قعد يرقص ويتنطط ويهزر ويعمل
حركات سبايدر مان وفجاه قرر انه ينط على
حد مننا عشان بالنسبه له ده الشرير اللي
سبايدر مان
بيحكم اخر مره رحنا لابراهيم ابراهيم كان
بيترق علينا كان بيهزر كان مبسوط كان
بيضحك وحتى بيغش في الالعاب اللي
بنلعبها لما بصينا لاجزاء الا سيمتريه في
كلامه خلقنا قصه جديده وحدث سعيد بطناه
وزرعنا فيه حلم لسه هنستخدم الحلم ده عشان
نعرف كلكل امنياته اللي هنقدر
نحققها احنا في الاول كنا بصين على
ابراهيم على انه كنا كنا بصنا على الصوره
الكبيره الصوره اللي طلعنا فيها اهتماماته
الاساسيه وهي المرض والعلاج
والمستشفى بس اول ما بصينا الحاجات
الغريبه اللي كانت بتحصل وبتتقل هي دي
اللي وصلتنا لل ستيت اوف مايند اللي
ابراهيم يقدر يحلم فيها ويحقق اللي نفسه
فيه ويعرف ان مرض ده جزء من الصوره بس مش
هو الصوره كلها ال سيمتريه في تفكير واللا
سيمتريه في اختيار الاحداث هي اللي وصلتنا
لكده ال سيمتريه هي مجرد وصله ما بين ما
انت واقف دلوقتي واي مكان انت ممكن تروحه
ابراهيم بالنسبه للكل كان طفل مريض كان
طفل سرطان كان طفل ربنا يشفيه ماحدش كان
باصص لاصغر حاجات بتحصل وبتتقل وبتبص وفي
الواقع ولا ابراهيم ذات نفسه ابراهيم
ماكانش محتاج ان احنا نشتغل على اكبر حاجه
هو ممكن يكون عايزها عشان يلبسه بل بالعكس
اصغر حاجات اشتغلنا عليها
هي اللي بسطته ورجعت له ثقته لنفسه من
جديد ابراهيم بقى ابراهيم الفرحان ابراهيم
وائل جمعه ابراهيم الرسام ابراهيم سبايدر
مان ابراهيم البطل ولو طفل عنده 11 سنه
يقدر يكون كل ده فما بقلك انت تقدر تكون
ايه انت مش مش حزين بس ولا مبسوط بس انت
مش مريض بس او عاجز بس ولا سليم بس انت مش
فاشل بس ولا ناجح بس كل ده انت اختيارك
لشيء واحد من اختلافات وتسيب الباقي ده
بيقلل جزء من كونك انت انت ممكن تزقطط
وتفرح وتنبسط لما تعمل حاجه كوويسه وتحزن
وتغضب وتتنرفز لما تعمل حاجه وحشه وتصلحها
عشان تبقى شيء كويس ممكن في شده مرضك
تساعد غيرك وتاخذ من مساعدته قوه ليك
وممكن تطلب من حد انه يساعدك في حياتك انت
ممكن ترجع تمشي وتتنطط وترقص تاني لو انت
عاجز ممكن تقول لحد لو سمحت
ساعدني انت ممكن تنجح في اللي انت بتحبه
وتفشل في اللي انت مش بتحبه انت ببساطه
تقدر تعمل كل اللي غيرك بيعرف او ما
بيعرفش
يعمله كل اختلافات دي لو انت تقبلتها هي
اللي هتكمل بقيه صورتك كانسان
[تصفيق]
شكرا